how are you Harrison I'm doing I'm doing
well thanks I'm young you bet absolutely
so first things first is this defense
taking on the Saints what do you believe
is your greatest challenge going into
this game Harrison I mean they have a
ton of weapons you know all across the
board and you know in the backfield at
receiver but I think you know a guy like
Drew Brees who's who's been there and
done that for for everything you know
that's where it starts and he you know
he's obviously playing playing at an
awesome an awesome level and he has his
own career so what did you see
facing him in Week one that you can
bring into this game knowledge-wise
Harrison um you know it's you know it's
it's easy to talk about you know just
you know doing an assignment covering
your guys but at the end of the day like
I said he's he's kind of seen at all you
know he's made the plays he's one of the
game's so we we really just have to
focus on ourselves trust and trust in
what we do and and really have
confidence and one another on the on the
defensive side of the ball well what is
it that you do how would you describe it
this Vikings defense Harrison um you
know we we obviously all want to take
care of our assignment but you know
beyond that I think as a collective unit
we we love to play the game no we love
game day running around with passion
everybody trying to get to the ball and
playing it for one another and no
coaches players alike so I think you
know that that passion for the game is
really what what we're about well how is
Emma changed things
since he's stepped in there I mean it
know he's been here for a while now but
uh I don't know he's uh he's what you
see what he's kind of like you know like
what you see is what you get he's gonna
tell you tell you like it is he's he's
gonna make sure that you played tough
physical smart football and and if
you're not he's he's gonna let you know
about it so you know there's no there's
no glitz black-and-white and we know uh
we know for right and we know for wrong
so that makes it simple for us well yeah
because I mean reason why I asked that
question is because for all the years
that I was covering the sport all I
heard is how great
position coach he was and then great
coordinator he was and then he finally
got the shot to be a coach in Minnesota
Harrison and I'm just trying to see what
what the secret sauce for him is cuz
every single player that I've worked
with that's been coached by him said
they'd run through a wall for him yeah
and like you said it's you know since he
started out as a position Coates and
then a coordinator and now nothing's
changed he continues to improve himself
too and and demands from those around
him but you know that you know guys
saying they run through a wall farmers
you know I think starts with you know we
know how committed he is he's gonna do
everything in his power to put us in the
right spots and so we we want to make it
right you know he's trying to help us
and we were to help him Harrison Smith's
Viking safety here on the Rich Eisen
show what does chimera present
problematically for you yeah he's uh you
know he's kind of exploded on the scene
tough runner you know he can he can run
in between the tackles and then
obviously in the past game he's doing
some great things he can you know he he
can run like a receiver has great hands
he he just overall has it has a really
good feel for the game and I mean kind
of asking these questions know it should
give away but you don't want to give
away but I mean are you gonna have a
role in personally stopping him
schematically do you think um well I
mean if he has the ball we're all gonna
strike it to him but you know this
there's always matchups all across the
field you never know where we're gonna
be you know how they're gonna use guys
so no matter what you know whoever you
line up across this you know just try to
execute you this honor well I mean you
know about running the ball yourself
from your high school days correct yeah
I don't know if I can fall back but uh
yeah I I used to Devon I think I think
every skill positions to say they were
the best running back around mm-hmm and
so you are the best running back that
you that was there in Knoxville
Tennessee right I mean I have to you
know continue continue saying that you
know just like it's yes
that's like quarterback slash wide
receiver in Florida
Cindy Howe was the best for
turn man you know that's how it is for
everybody well technically Camaro was
the best running back in Knoxville
Tennessee last year right Harrison when
you say that oh yeah I kind of forgot
about that
yes how come how come you wound up
wearing a golden dome how come you
weren't part of staying home just didn't
work out at the time I actually did grow
up a ball fan but uh you know once I
started going through high school you
know I kind of drifted away from it and
decided to get out of town get out of
town and then go and and and play for
Notre Dame you know you know what my
school is right Harrison are you aware
of what my school I it is the school up
north right it is well yeah it's a
school up north it is that yeah you know
you know and and we're we're renewing a
rivalry that Notre Dame stopped okay so
that's coming up very soon
so I have to ask you the question that I
asked all Notre Dame guys whether it's
Bettis or anybody else has been on the
show is Rudy real or fake is that fake
or real Rudy it's real it happened
come on yeah I mean it happened there's
you can watch the tape
check tape being carried off by the
entire team with uh no I mean I guess I
don't know if that happened or not I
don't but I know he was out there mm-hmm
now I know it cuz you're a regular guy
is it true
Harrison Smith that you all-pro but not
a Pro Bowler we'll get to that in a
second that you are driving the same
truck that you have driven your entire
driving life is that a true story that
is true and Astrix okay I have another
vehicle but that is that's my daily
go-to guy which is what your 2002-2003
Tahoe okay well I mean does it have a
tape deck in it I mean like what what's
in that thing
it actually
did have a tape back in it but I I took
it out and I put a bench seat in the
front
okay so you've souped it up you've
you've modernized all right yeah yeah
what type of dog do you have chocolate
chocolate lab chocolate lab named Brady
after the greatest Michigan Wolverine of
all time Rudy did you call the dog Rudy
then is a dog named Rudy juice he's like
he's the second okay I like it okay so
the chocolate lab deuce sitting right
there in the middle of the right in the
car you're just a regular guy so why why
did you not make the Pro Bowl do you
think Harrison why um I mean I don't
know it's you know that's how it goes
sometimes you can say it every year
about different guys I mean it's not
like it's not really in like until I
could control my play so all the other
stuff cool if it happens it doesn't just
keep playing okay and what does it mean
for a former running back as we as we've
established of note to be named an All
Pro defender in the National Football
League for you yeah you know it's I'm
obviously honored by that well I hadn't
I'd never been named Otto before so that
was that's Karma cool new thing for me
yeah that's about it okay so you don't
want to pat yourself on the back is what
you're saying okay the way we play you
know there's a lot of good players
around the end we play off one another
okay see there is there but there is an
I in Harrison and an i and Smith but
your team players basically what you're
telling me right now I understand that
yeah but you gotta have confidence you
know go make your place mm-hmm how cold
is it there so I know because you know
I'm coming there
you know we're coming for the Superbowl
whether we're having it or not so it it
recently we had a we had a lot of heat
recently you got it right around 30 32 I
think I think this weekend the negatives
so come on come
yeah is that it feels like is that I
feel no real temperature-
feels like the other day it feels like
negative yeah that feels like is what
gets you that's definitely one get you
we were low temperature is fine is it
negative 20 wind chills but it's is it a
dry cold at least try coal is not a good
cold hopefully we'll get hopefully we'll
get a heatwave when you come into town
Wow so so what do you do to keep warm
I mean well how many layers the how many
layers dis Harrison Smith all field all
field now and I understand your your
grown-ass man on the field and you're
playing doors too but if you got to go
outdoors I understand you're not you're
not you're not afraid of that but off
you know Harrison's modestly yeah I
don't spend a lot of time outside and
weigh in and run in from my car the
facility hits about 15 yards yeah and
then I just won't go outside
well okay because that call you it's no
good on your face
well feeling invited me to go ice
fishing when I come there regardless
whether in the Super Bowl or not would
you do that
if Thielen took me ice fishing would you
join I've actually I've actually been
talking to people about doing that you
know it's my sixth year up here and I
still haven't still haven't checked that
out but I've heard it's a good time okay
so here's what we're gonna do a Harrison
Smith feelin's gonna take me and you ice
fishing and we're gonna have a
competition to see who catches something
first how about that
I don't I also don't know how much skill
is involved I think you just kind of
hang out Harrison Harrison Harrison I'm
a 48 year old Jewish man who who
basically fishes when I eat I eat fish I
don't I don't stick a line in the water
man you like how I do it you would have
the advantage merely despite strolling
into the ice house with me and feeling
okay if you want I'll give you I'll give
you up yeah you'll be plus half a fish
how's that if you Harrison look man I
love the way you play football
I love the way you play football it's
fun to watch and I look forward to
seeing you ball out this weekend and
however long the football godsey
fortunate to have you on the field this
year thank you very much you bet man
we'll see you soon Ostara I'm really
gonna play that music for him okay I
love it
see I could see right now Rudy out there
pulling his hamstring that's not the way
it ended okay good good to chat with you
Harrison you take care all right thanks
okay Matt Harrison Smith the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience